All right.
Laura Lauder, thank you so much
for being on my show.
How are you?
Thank you, Michael.
It's a pleasure to be here.
I am incredibly excited for this
because I've heard so much about you.
I've worked with you through J-Ventures.
I've seen you
being the chair of J-Ventures,
and reading about all the different
incredible things that you've done.
It's inspiring.
And the impact
that you're having hands-on
is just remarkable.
And I would love to spend these 20 minutes
to talk about your journey.
I want to talk about philanthropy.
I want to talk about
philanthropic venture capital.
I want to talk about your work
with J-Ventures, and the different
Jewish organizations here
and what that means to you.
But first of all, Laura,
right before we started this,
you mentioned sports.
That sports got you
into this competitive nature,
which is very evident also
in the space that you're in today.
So, talk to me a little bit
about this passion for sports
and how you get started.
Great. Okay, Michael.
Thanks so much for doing this.
I think these podcasts
are just so relevant.
It gives folks an insight into how people
got to the place that they are.
I mean, I'm pushing 60 here.
And even though you can't tell
by my hair color,
I love the fact that
I used to be a young person
and always looked up to folks
who've done much more.
And so, it's wonderful
that you're doing this.
Thank you very much.
I appreciate it.
So, in terms of how I grew up,
the reality is that I grew up
in a small town in Ohio, Midwest.
My father was involved
in international business.
And so, he was gone a lot at the time.
But he used to
bring me back wonderful toys
and wonderful cultural gifts
from his travels.
And one of the things that he was also
very passionate about, was tennis.
And so, as a child growing up,
I was always very very enthusiastic
about beating Dad in order to show him
that he had a great kid to come home to
whenever he came back from these travels.
And as a result,
I became a competitive tennis player.
I'll never forget when I was 16,
I actually challenged my dad
to a big match.
He had been playing all his life.
And I was very very passionate
about tennis.
And I challenge him to have a big match.
And what was going to be the reward?
A new used car for me
so I could drive myself
to tennis tournaments.
And that imbued a whole passion
for being competitive.
And then, once I won that car from him,
because I definitely beat him,
you could probably have guessed that,
I ended up playing college tennis.
And college tennis
was a very different experience.
Because I was so much focused
on individual competitions.
But now, playing as a team
that collaborative spirit,
and yet we were as a team,
competitive against other schools,
that made me a much better,
let's just say, partner and teammate
in the greater world.
So, sports has always provided a way
for me not only to stay healthy and fit,
and hopefully not look too much
like I'm pushing 60,
but definitely a way of life
and a way to collaborate with others
in this competitive world.
I love it.
So, what is it about
this competitive nature
in this collaborative world?
Because I took part in First Robotics,
a robotics competition back in Israel,
but also in the US.
And one of the wonderful things
that Dean Kamen,
the founder of it says, is Coopetition.
Cooperation and competition.
Which resonates a lot
to what you're saying here
about your experience with tennis
and now into this other world.
What is it about this coopetition
that you find useful
in your journey today?
So, Michael, one of the things
that I found is that,
as a philanthropist,
when I married Gary Lauder
and I realized I was moving
into a new world of philanthropy.
I'd always been passionate
about philanthropy.
But I had a career in tech.
And I was a salesperson
for an IBM mainframe software company,
370 Architecture.
Wow.
COBOL code generators
and that whole world in the 80s.
Once I moved out of that
and married Gary when I was 30,
I've realized that I had to step up
my game in the philanthropy world
because that was going to be
my new future.
Gary and I like to joke
that he, now as a venture capitalist,
likes to make money
and I try to give it away, and I'm faster.
So, what I try to do,
is try to use our philanthropy
to fill gaps where there's no one else
perhaps focused in this area,
and our added value
is going to really make the difference.
It's going to bridge
where people are today,
to what a future could look like.
Now, in order to do that,
that's a highly competitive space
because you have to collaborate
with the people on one hand
and then hand off to the other hand.
So, for example, here's an example.
Our children were going
to a Jewish day school.
And at that Jewish day school,
they had the most wonderful teachers.
The Gideon Houseman Jewish Day School
in Palo Alto, California.
But what I realized is that
these kinds of teachers weren't there.
You didn't see fantastic teachers
like these in all schools.
So, I said, we've got to find a way
to build a pipeline of Jewish teachers
who are passionate about teaching
and passionate about tikkun olam,
and passionate about
integrating Jewish values
into the curriculum.
So, there was this big gap of a pipeline
of Jewish day school teachers.
So, I created this program called DeLeT.
Which, as you know, is Hebrew for door.
It was opening the door
to a career in teaching.
And we have now trained
hundreds and hundreds
of Jewish day school teachers.
Like a Jewish Teach for America.
And that never existed before.
But we had to collaborate
with all of the schools
because they had to tell us
what the criteria were
for the best teachers.
We had to collaborate
with the universities
that were training teachers.
We had to collaborate
with any number of different organizations
that were feeder's into our program.
But we had to make ourselves the best
in terms of excellence and standards
so that we could scale this.
Because the two most important words
in philanthropy, are leverage and scale.
If you can lever other organizations
to feed your pipeline,
and you can scale it
so that has impact,
then, you've really done something well.
That is exactly what I'm curious about.
Because before, when you're saying
that spending money,
that doesn't do justice
to what you're doing.
You're using resources
to make a lasting impact on people.
And I'm really curious
about this latter part,
this lasting impact.
And how do you actually use resources
to go and transform institutions,
different industries
and different people's lives
so that they can pay it forward
and then transform
other people's lives?
So, how do you do that at scale?
Because sometimes, it seems that
a lot of the endeavors
that people do in philanthropy,
they're short lived,
or they are very specific to one segment.
How do you go about,
strategically thinking,
how do I take something like DeLet
and make it at scales
so that every one of those teachers
can influence another teacher
and dozens of students
who will then grow up
to be educators themselves
and mentors themselves?
Exactly.
Well, you've said it about DeLeT.
So, I'll give you another example.
Yes.
So, our kids, both that
we're thinking about doing a gap year,
both before college or after college.
And when we really thought about
what are the impacts
that young people can make,
a lot of folks say,
"Somebody 18 years old,
but really, what benefit
can they provide to the world in terms of
really doing something impactful?"
Well, when you talk about scale,
then you can think about
what Israel does, which is fantastic
in terms of enabling young people
to do a gap year
before they join the army.
And it's a service year.
I did that at school, yeah.
Not a service year,
but I did a different gap year.
Right. So, in the United States,
we have something called AmeriCorps.
Only 80,000 young people
are eligible to do AmeriCorps
in terms of the funding
by the federal government
at $25,000 per kid.
There are 600,000 applicants.
So, a group of us
at the Aspen Institute worked with
four star General Stanley McChrystal,
who desperately wanted to create
a national program with huge scale
so that there are now
a million young people
serving in the military
in the United States.
He wanted to see a million young people
serving their country,
doing national service.
And right now, we're at 80,000.
But the demand is there.
So, how can we scale that up?
So, a group of us started
a wonderful new program
called the Service Year Alliance.
And we collaborated
with all kinds of non-profits
across the country.
And we're working to try to enable
every young person
who wants to do a service here
to be able to do that at age 18 to 26.
And just this week,
we have introduced legislation
into the United States Senate.
Co-sponsored by eight Democrats
and eight Republicans,
called the Corps Act.
C-O-R-P-S
And that piece of legislation
we're hoping to include
into that the Republicans version
of the Covid Relief Act,
and that would enable
250,000 young people
to do a year of national service.
So, scale is absolutely critical.
And at the end of the day,
public, private partnerships
are the best way to do that.
And what it sounds to me from that story,
it's not just about the resources,
it's about the relationships,
and it's about the strategic
entrepreneurial mindset of how do we get
from 80,000 to 250,000
with the collaboration
from different organizations
around the US showing that
there is a product market fit, right?
You have 600,000 applicants
who want to do this.
This is not just the dream
that you're selling somebody on,
this is a reality that is just
there's a bottleneck
that you have to turn the switch
and make it happen.
And there's a matching component.
So, it is very very much a tech platform.
So, if you go on to the service,
your alliance website,
serviceyear.org,
you'll see that you could put in criteria.
I want to teach fifth grade in New Orleans
starting in September of 2021,
and a list of opportunities will come up
and you can apply to them directly
through the website.
Making super easy for young people
to apply to these service positions
is really the key to making it successful.
Wonderful.
Laura, talk to me a little bit
about your Jewish identity
and why are you so excited
and passionate about this,
both your Jewish identity,
but also looking at it as a bit broader,
putting together the Israeli identity
and the Jewish identity
and the different groups
and what's happening here in the US
and the Bay Area.
Obviously, we're seeing the rise
of antisemitism around the world,
which is horrifying.
And I believe just last week
we had swastikas on Stanford campus.
So, it's all around us always.
And you're very very involved
with your Jewish identity
in the Jewish community.
So, I'd love to get a little bit
of inspiration into that.
Also, myself as an Israeli
and a Jewish citizen
here in the Bay Area,
with all my family back in Israel.
Great question, Michael.
In the United States,
you have to choose
to be Jewish today.
People can assimilate
and not be involved.
When you live in Israel,
and you grew up in Israel,
it's just part of life.
And it's part of your identity
that in ways that sometimes is negative
because there are so many ultra-Orthodox.
The Haredim destroyed
a lot of the culture of what is really
authentically Jewish, I think.
Right.
So, my sense of Judaism is this
positive, joyful values based identity
that I hope I got from my parents.
And I hope to be teaching now
to my children.
And what I would say to you
is that raising kids
is a very difficult thing to do.
And when you have a framework of values
that enable you to teach them
not only by the texts that are ancient,
but also, by the deeds,
the mitzvot that you do every day
so that kids learn by example.
That to me is the framework
of what Judaism provides
that is so valuable to me.
It's the history, the tradition,
the values, the culture,
the land, the language.
It's all of these things together.
And so, as a result of that,
I have gotten very involved in Jewish life
ever since I was very young.
So, I mentioned that
I was a tennis player.
My very first experience in Israel
was teaching at the Israel Tennis Center
in Ramat Hasharon.
I trained there.
No kidding.
Yeah. I'm a tennis player myself. Yes.
Wonderful. Yofi. Yofi.
Well, we loved playing tennis
at the Israel Tennis Center.
And then by the time
my kids were old enough,
our son was a big tennis player.
Our daughter played them, too.
That was one of the places
that we took them,
on our son's bar mitzvah trip.
So that they could play tennis
with Israeli teens
and folks who weren't just Jewish.
I mean, as you know,
there are Arab Israelis
who also play in the 13 or 14
different Israel tennis centers
around the country.
And the values associated
with teaching kids to play tennis,
learning the values of hard work
and discipline and practice.
And then also, the tutoring piece,
which, as you know, also happens
at the Israel Tennis Center.
And then countries around the world
came to Israel to say,
"How did you create
this wonderful tennis program
that enables kids to learn from each other
and also integrate
the communities together?"
Who cares if you're from an Arab community
or a Jewish community,
or, a Bedouin community?
Tennis is tennis.
And on the court,
everybody has to be a team player
and has to be a good competitor.
So, I just love the values
that Judaism has created
and it puts it to play
and to work in Israel.
I love it. I love it.
Laura, how do you manage your time?
You're doing so many different things.
Just preparing for this
and reading on all the different sources,
it's overwhelming the number of things
that you've done.
Very involved also with NPR
on their board.
How do you manage your time at the end?
Because you have so much to give, right?
You have so many different
passions and ideas.
And we were transitioning from sports
to AmeriCorps, to Judaism.
How do you balance your time
so that you can both provide impact
to these organizations who need your time,
because at the end,
the people are looking at you
as a leader, at the same time,
allowing yourself to branch out
and take risks on other endeavors
and continue to evolve and scale?
Well, first and foremost,
I have to give a lot of credit
to my sweet husband, Gary,
who just supports me
in every way possible.
So, and then secondarily,
to our two kids, Josh and Eliana,
who went to the
Gideon Houseman Jewish Day School,
have great values and are living
really positive impact lives right now.
And as a result of the fact
that I have really,
I'm very very fortunate
to have a healthy family,
both physically as well as emotionally,
they are a great support system.
We are a great support system
for each other.
So, that is the core.
And family values of our core family
is really critical.
The second thing I would say to you
is living a healthy lifestyle.
Like I am now a crazy maniac biker.
I love biking with a lot of Israelis
because they're very competitive.
And so, I bike a lot with Zach Renaud.
I don't know if you know that.
But Zach and I,
just actually biked for a week
here in Aspen, Colorado last week,
and he put me to shame.
So, I'm trying to keep up
with Zach and Orly.
But, I would also say to you
that managing your time
in terms of making sure
that you're focusing on your priorities,
that is the critical element.
I don't, frankly, I hate to say it,
I have not seen a television show
and I don't know how long.
We have dinners with friends outside
during this coronavirus pandemic,
almost every single night.
So, we're connecting with people.
We're hearing their ideas.
We're keeping this balance of life
with exercise, with friends,
with family, and, of course,
with our passions.
So, I'm on 11 boards.
And these boards are very time consuming.
My most recent board
is the National Constitution Center
in Philadelphia, which educates the world
about the American constitution.
Wanted a critical civics education today.
It's so important.
Especially today.
But I can't get involved
in any of these things,
unless I really have a balance in my life.
There's one other
really wonderful initiative
that I've just taken on.
And it's initiative
that Oded and I, have created.
It's called Shomrim
and which means, the Guardians.
And this is a ProPublica for Israel.
So, this is an opportunity
for us to provide
philanthropic journalism at its best.
Investigative journalism,
providing the best of news stories
to the existing media on social issues.
Not about politics,
not about the military,
not about the conflict.
It's about the social issues
that are applied today in Israel.
And I love Israel so much
that I want to make sure that Israel
is the best it can possibly be.
And I think investigative journalism
helps a country become as it can be.
So, among all of those things,
I can't pick one favorite.
It's just, it's all my baby.
It's the passion exudes from the screen.
And lastly, we have to talk
about J-Ventures,
that I've gotten involved with as well.
And I've been so inspired by Oded
and the team there,
and really the community
that is being built.
So, I've gotten to know,
especially through this show,
a lot of different VCs.
And I can very honestly, genuinely say,
I've never seen a community as strong
and as genuine as J ventures.
Especially going into due diligences
with 10 LPs who are each incredibly busy.
And working together.
because we enjoy working together,
checking the ego at the door
as [--]
said on the show.
He's also an LP there.
And you're chair of J-Ventures.
And one of the missions
is to connect to the the Jewish
and Israeli community together
and create magic there.
Now, we're both working
on the Next Generation project
for young Israelis and Jewish.
So, talk to me a little bit
about your involvement
with the J-Ventures
and why that fund?
And what are we trying to do there?
Sure.
So, let me just correct you
one thing, Michael.
I'm not the chair of J-Ventures.
That's Oded and Jim Koshland.
What I'm the chair of
is this community outreach element.
So, the philanthropic piece of it.
So, as we begin to have exits
and we have some
philanthropic capital then
to put into play,
we now want to encourage
the next generation of J-Ventures
to participate in everything
that we're doing.
So, that's the objective there.
But the reason why I was involved
with Oded at the very beginning,
to help him create J-Ventures,
was really to bring our passions together
into one community.
To integrate folks,
to give them opportunities to meet others.
Can you imagine there are many
American Jews who don't know Israelis
in an intimate way.
To know what are the issues
that they have faced
as young people growing up in Israel
or young people growing up here
with an Israeli identity.
So, we share the Zionism passion.
But we also share
this legacy of Judaism
and of those values
that I dare say,
some Israelis don't value
as much as American Jews do.
And so, seeing the passion
for tikkun olam of American Jews
and the passion for community
based on Judaism,
that's a rare thing for some Israelis.
And so, to bring these
two communities together
to share their common purpose
and passions,
I think it's a really worthwhile endeavor.
I love it.
Laura, for myself
and for other young entrepreneurs
and engineers going through their journey,
what should we keep in mind
as we go along for our futures,
whether it would be in tech,
or education, or whatever it may be,
what are some core values
that you now, looking back,
see are a foundation for who you are
that we should take with us as well?
I think one of the most important elements
for all of us is balance.
It's this question that we talked about
a few minutes ago, Michael, where
we have to have a life
that is not so stressful
that we are constantly battling
our inner demons
about what is the right thing to do,
what's the best thing for us to do.
There's no one right answer.
And so, to have whether
it's mindfulness and meditation,
or hardcore exercise out on a bike
for a couple of hours,
or a way for you to just make sure
that you stay in touch with who you are
and what's important to you,
that, to me, is a key element
of any successful person.
And I have to say that
as a young entrepreneur going through,
and especially here in the Bay Area,
the lines get blurred
and it's very easy to all of a sudden
find yourself working in those
17, 18 hour days on various projects
and without even having the time
before going to bed to sit down,
reflect on what's important
and what are the priorities.
And that's definitely something
that I'm taking to heart as well.
So, thank you for the inspiration.
Laura, before we go,
I want to thank you for your generosity
and for everything that you're doing,
but also for your generosity
with your time here for this show.
I really appreciate it.
And I would like to ask for three words
that you would use to describe yourself,
or that Gary would use to describe you,
or anybody else that's worked with you.
Okay. So, I think I will say,
And I did not prepare you for this.
So, I'm not holding those three words.
I didn't give enough time ahead.
I guess, I care a lot.
So, I'm caring.
I'm highly energetic.
Yeah.
And I'm passionate, as you can tell.
Of course. I love it.
Laura, thank you very much. Toda raba.
I look forward to continue watching
the amazing things that you're doing.
And thank you for all the inspiration.
Bye.